ben would you like to hit some headlines
with us i would want nothing more than
to hit some headlines come on
thank you
take it away then
first up a story from thrillist they are
reporting that spice fusion a tasty
little spot in kent england has a new
promo offer exclamation point
there is a tiny phone jail provided at
every table and if everyone in your
party locks up their phone at dinner you
get 20 20 off and that's 20 off apps
entrees drinks the whole shebang
everything they're calling it the dinner
is better when we eat together promotion
i
love this
yeah i
[Applause]
when we're all on our phones i feel like
we don't get to connect and all that
stuff so i love the idea of putting our
phones in a little thing and talking i'm
i and to get 20 off oh my goodness two
things i love so it's like i'm into this
would you do it
i i so um i went to um
a a thing recently should i say what it
was yes okay we'll bleep it out in post
we'll bleep it out it was a madonna
event and it was very intimate and small
and of course i was like let's okay so
you get there and they lock your phone
up in a thing and they don't give it to
you they're like no put it in and we'll
give it to you when you when you leave
and you're like okay
great good yes thank you i i mean how
many times have you done that when
you're at dinner with someone and you're
like oh my god i'm putting my phone down
i'm sorry and then 30 seconds later
you're like but i just want to check
insta i do it all the time and i feel
like this would give me major anxiety
this is the only way you could get me to
skip dessert if you had to like you can
have it when the meal is over i'd like
rush through but i love the sentiment of
this you know like we're all sitting
down we should be looking each other in
the eye we should be communicating we
should be forgetting about the rest of
the world so i love it in theory in
practice it gives me anxiety can i see a
show of hands of who
you know and remember we get a discount
here
who would be game for this raise of
hands this is amazing
um i don't know maybe
what if people started doing this even
at home you know is there any sort of
incentive yeah like at home phones down
bones down yeah yeah i i love the phones
down i love a phone's down
all right well next up we've got news on
the science of laughter this is
interesting the bbc reports a new study
proves that laughter from a studio
audience or even
canned laugh tracks can actually make
jokes funnier this is something that
sitcoms have known for years and now a
study played some real real growner dad
jokes for their subjects and when they
paired it with laughs the joke's
actually rated as funnier um so guess
what i have some of those jokes right
yeah
i love it that's a laugh we have a laugh
track now these are not good jokes you
understand but they're going to be funny
because listen ready how about this why
can't you give elsa a balloon
because she'll let it go she'll just let
it go
all right that's a kid's joke i know
that one but listen did you hear the
laugh track
i i this
psychologically speaking this feels
understandable how like a cacophony of
laughter could envelop you and kind of
pick you up and get you swept up in it
well it's like when you watch sitcoms
remember cheers always said cheers is
taped in front of a live studio audio
that's right and like the laughter at
home helps sell sell the jokes and bet
when you're on stage thank you
i liked it yeah it made you laugh oh my
gosh
it's so spooky i hated that that's not
scary to anybody else because it's fake
it sounds like people from the 60s
trapped in a room being forced to laugh
like play at one party play well i'm
going to say a dramatic just listen how
it's all so spooky um actually i'm sorry
but your um
your father is in the hospital
that's
terrifying
i hate that don't you let listen to how
lively you can respond to these humans
laughs yeah it's not good like it's
funny it works if you say a punchline
but if you say like i have a weird rash
that's funny you're right
in the hospital i laughed because i
always laugh at naughty things or when
you're not supposed to laugh i
feel like i have my own personal
nightmare laugh track that i can't
control and it's like coming out it's
like if i am somewhere where i'm not
supposed to laugh i'm like constantly
holding that laugh track inside oh yeah
or if somebody tells me horrible news
i'm like oh god it's uncomfortable and
the first thing i want to do is laugh
because it's the wrong response yes so i
just i have someone inside of me with
like a pitchfork
you know just gunning for me to laugh i
i relate to that left track i would
really like to have a button that
controls that laugh track so if i'm ever
out here one day and a joke doesn't go
over i can just be like
there you go
[Music]